I'm very surprised that I've had these
experiences in certain movies that have
really been impactful in some way often
surprising you know even hocus-pocus and
you know la story or Atwood Mars Attacks
you know sex and City these are all
things that they've been resonant with
people for many years I feel that's an
unusual experience to have more than one
of those and and I feel lucky
hocus-pocus
I've only seen it once I saw the
premiere when it the week before it
opened I guess there was a premiere in
Los Angeles and that's the only time
I've seen it so I I'm often like not
able to answer a lot of questions I mean
I just obviously we just there's a big
anniversary right now so so I did an
interview and I've been reminded of some
stuff but mostly I only see something
one time it's preferable for me I it's
not pleasant for me to watch myself when
you're watching at least I find myself
in a movie I feel like I'm paying
attention to things that I think are
less important than than the story that
it's telling sometimes you're
experiencing the day that you were
shooting but I really do think audiences
remember much more about it than I do I
remember more the experience of shooting
it than I do the story like I'm not
entirely sure I could tell you the main
character's names the children's
characters names but the process of
shooting was very long it was unusually
long shooting schedule because I think
of the special effects and actually a
bunch of people got sick so we shut down
for a while somebody said to me well
were you surprised it wasn't a bigger
hit and I was like I had no idea I
thought it was and I remember
specifically the weekend that it opened
I was in Los Angeles still I guess
because I was out there doing press and
the phone rang very early on a Saturday
morning I think and it was Jeffrey
Katzenberg like screaming like we made 9
million
so my experience wasn't with him he was
a great success
well it certainly made its money back la
story I got a call from my agent and
there was a casting director in Los
Angeles I think her name was Mindy Marin
and she was casting that this new Steve
Martin movie that he'd written and I
loved Steve Martin and you know knew a
huge amount about his work and and and
very particular things about the way he
worked and so I loved him and and I you
know very much you know who wanted one
of the part but it seemed like a real
long shot to me and for some reason I I
understood her I understood I thought I
understood what I sort of assumed Steve
Martin imagined as he wrote this part
and I enjoyed myself it wasn't an
audition where I was really nervous
which you know one can be yeah and then
I just kept getting called back and I
did a screen test with Steve Martin
which is really fun and you know
terrifying also like but I yeah then I
got the part and and got to got to play
at Sandy in LA story is um you know she
has like no definition really she's sort
of this floating ever-changing this
person who's soaking up other ideas of
of a definition or an identity and you
know she's foolish and silly and doesn't
seem terribly bright I mean she's
probably brighter than she lets on but
for some reason I think thinks she has
to maybe she's more attractive if she's
not smart some memories on movies become
sort of mushy you know you're you
remember an experience rather than
specificity but I yeah I remember
vividly many scenes in particular I
think from the beginning and I had this
idea that she would be moving all the
time that wasn't really written so much
in the script or the balance
there was specific movement that was
like almost like written as stage
direction and almost like choreography
but there was others that I just started
doing and eventually the the director of
makjang s'en who I loved and I had you
know he had done all these he had done
great films in in the UK and in London
he would eventually just get to the
point where he just had a megaphone
he'd say and bounce and action like he
was just it told me to bounce around um
but yeah I sort of remember all the
scenes and an end time off-camera as
well you know sitting waiting you know
kind of staring at Steve I guess for
some people it's it feels a little bit
like like it's a little bit you know an
amber it was a very specific time in a
way of observing the larger sort of
ideas about Los Angeles I'll have a
decaf coffee oh I'll have a double decaf
cappucino Jimmy to have made a coffee
ice cream or small of a half double
decaffeinated half cap but
my guess is that they'd be still really
accurate honeymoon vacant I think I got
the part in honeymoon in Vegas because
of la story and that's what Andy Bergman
told me when I when I met him I didn't
email audition for a honeymoon in Vegas
they just offered me the part which I
really couldn't believe I couldn't
believe I'd never been offered a part
especially a lead in a movie and like a
real major motion picture you know and
um she wasn't similar at all to sandy
which is what's what surprised me about
you know being cast based on LA story
but I Betsy and in honeymoon in Vegas is
really bright she's a schoolteacher you
know she's a professional person and
shows up every day and is in fact um you
know very I conventional it's the
opposite of sandy you know who defies
all convention and doesn't believe in
any conventions period
Betsy is like a teacher who believes and
kind of rules and like a model for
living but funny because she's written
by Andy Bergman who's you know one of
great great comedy screenwriters I read
with all the men there were many many
auditions and screen tests and it was
very apparent to everybody the minute
that and it came in I mean there was
just nothing more to be said and nobody
else to meet working with him was
fantastic I mean it was truly great and
inspired and fun and um you know
surprising very very surprising and it
just made my job easy in a way I mean
it's not easy but it there was really
like the most like perfect example of
listening responding because he's he's
so compelling
you know opposite and um yeah I loved
him working with James Caan was
incredible
he has this
very kind of amazing thing that I've
never seen in another actors eyes in my
entire life and I've stared stared
across and looked in the eyes of a lot
of actors and especially male actors his
eyes actually flicker it's a very I've
not seen anybody else's eyes actually
spark they sort of have flashes in them
that is it's really something and it can
be both terrifying and you know
seductive but when it's terrifying it's
it's really quite something
[Music]
Tim just you know had been pondering
this making this you know telling the
story for a very long time and he just
had like a wealth of stuff for me to
read and look at and that was really
important but then it there comes a
point where um you're just trying to be
real given you know given your script
and like the scenes that I had to play I
think the harder part is just I really
wanted to mimic those scenes that we
were recreating which was an amazing
experience like we were really like
within like the scale like everything
and to me that was the most that's the
thing I wanted to be most authentic
about the rest of it you can't quite do
when you're playing somebody real you
don't want it you know then you get too
caught up in um things that you have no
control over but the recreation of those
scenes was hugely exciting and and and
like fun to sort out and get right and I
listened over and over again and watched
out those clips over and over again I
think that they're pretty they're pretty
close you know working for Tim Burton um
and that was the first time I did
another movie with him shortly after
that and I you know he's just absolutely
fantastic to work for because he's so
clear it's so specific you know every
frame is you understand so so well what
he wants
Mostafa city is enormous ly helpful
you're like really fitting into like a
painting that he's a
kind of already created and I like that
I love working with Johnny Depp I
thought he was really sweet and great to
work with great on the set to everybody
human deeply human and um you know just
loved his work he loved his work he
loved being an actor and an Martin
Landau played Bela Lugosi and he won an
Oscar
today was thrilling and so deserved I
mean he'd been around for so long it had
been he's been doing great work for a
really long time and he was such a good
kind man so humble you know he was a
journeyman he was just working all the
time and so happy to be working when he
was and he was a great lovely person
thanks Tim Burton just asked if I would
do Mars attack and I said yes I mean
anybody would have
I mean when I read the script everything
really all right she knows her sewer I
mean I just think anybody would would
want to work with Tim Burton and would
want to do no matter how strange kind of
help him fulfill his vision you know I
wasn't at all familiar with those kinds
of movies I mean with the exception of
of familiarizing myself with Ed Wood
genre and those movies I didn't really
know as much the movies that he was sort
of kind of recreating in a way you do
you kind of do what you're told in a way
that I really like you know there's
always a really strong costume designer
who's you know whose point of view is
like playing a really pivotal part in
what an audience is experiencing and the
hair and makeup departments always
really strong I mean there's all these
other creative influences that are
helping you so much yeah I turned into I
was a hertog I think it was her dog
Pierce Brosnan was involved in that was
he had like a mild like a crazy
scientist like a mad scientist yeah
something like that yeah I love that
part and once again that was a kind of
part I you know I'd never played that
before and I really really liked it I'm
I was very nervous in a way making that
movie not daily on the set but trying to
figure it out and Tom bazooka who wrote
and directed it Tom was really helpful
tom was really he was strict with me in
an interesting way you know he wanted me
to play this part and but he also wanted
pieces of me gone so it was interesting
and I was very happy to like I didn't
feel that he was not appreciative of
what I have to bring or my own skills
but he wanted something else for me and
and I part of that was really scary
because it it was being watched in a way
I felt and I was intimidated by Diane
Keaton even though I had I'd known her
we did you know First Wives Club years
before but I this was so intimately we
were in each other's faces so much and I
you know I wanted her to like me and um
but I I loved that movie I was really
proud of it I was proud of everybody's
work I was proud of my work and when I
saw it I I loved it I mean I really
loved it I love correcting else I mean
the whole cast is many people have gone
on those there were some folks in that
movie who were relatively unknown at the
time not unknown but you know Rachel
McAdams and Elizabeth freezer like these
were actresses that were just starting
to emerge and you know what I thought
Luke Wilson was so great in an enduring
like I thought there were such great
performances
[Music]
that part and that story and that you
know I think they are so daily in my
life like in ways that are you know
probably very obvious and then ways that
aren't whether it's you know people on
Instagram or walking down the street of
New York or people see me or me having a
memory of a you know cross street where
I shot you know two dozen or more scenes
so I feel like it's not far away but the
experience is in many ways and and I
feel for the most part I feel fine about
it I mean I had hopes that we would get
to make another movie and I was excited
I think because it finally felt right in
the story so I I mostly feel great like
I love where we got to leave all of them
I think they're all probably doing
really well and still enjoying that
friendship and their city or maybe some
of left at Charlotte might have finally
moved to the suburbs
my guess is but it's a you know it's a
real privilege to have that not just the
memory of the experience but have the
connection with the audience that that
was initially you know along with us and
discovering us but today a whole new
generation of young women stop me
literally every single day of my life to
share their feelings and thoughts and
affection for this show in the movie and
that's a that's a privilege you know
it's a it's a professional blessing no
doubt
[Music]
it's not so much that I feel carry
within me I mean you know we would have
stretches of time and then we come back
to work and you would sort it out pretty
quickly you'd like rediscover like a
muscle or something that is like
slightly atrophied on a hiatus or so you
find that stuff very quickly but it's uh
it's part of you in ways that you can't
start to articulate the ways in which
it's sort of it you know it it's in you
it's part of your memories it's part of
your most important professional moments
and years and time spent it's you know
incredibly sentimental and nostalgic but
the character isn't in me because I you
know she's somebody else's creation
really and I long to play other people
and other parts but you know if asked
him to find her again I could I could
manage here now well the character in
here now is her name is Vivian and she
is a singer with relative success in New
York she's had a career that she's both
that is both a source of pride and
frustration the movie really is a story
about a woman who gets a diagnosis and
it's and it's it's a portrait of this
next 24 hours in her life as she absorbs
this information and it's about love and
loss and I think coming to terms with
the role you've played in your own life
and the relationships you have with
those around you and within with the
city you know that both loves and
betrays you